the boy is the newest January horror
release and right there you're thinking
huh no but wait there's also a creepy
doll so it's bound to be great right
so when Annie played by lauren cohan is
hired by this British family to come to
their very creepy home in the middle of
nowhere to babysit their son for a while
oh and their son just so happens to be a
doll that they speak to as if it's
really alive fun times initially she
dismisses them as crazy people and she
just goes along with their charade for a
while because they're paying her very
well but soon she loses her shoes things
start disappearing things start moving
she hears strange noises at night and
she begins to think that maybe just
maybe this doll could be alive look I've
seen a lot of in January especially
horror films I've seen some guys
but I must be honest even though I want
to rip this movie to shreds this movie
is not as bad as most January horror
films movies like Texas Chainsaw 3d or
one missed call we've seen a lot of
creepy doll movies there's the Chucky
movies there's dead silence there's the
goosebumps movie there's Annabelle oh
god why do I remind myself that movie
exists this is not a new concept but I
admired the director's approach to this
movie he did create a lot of genuine
suspense and there are some sequences of
tension that surprise me the overall
production value and look of this movie
is very good the performances are also
good lauren cohan as well as Rupert
Evans from the Hellboy movies very good
performances very good work the general
field this movie was good and I did get
goosebumps a couple times there were a
few shots that gave me the tingles and
that's because of good suspense where
this movie faltered for me were a few
cliches one of them being the dream
sequence it happens once early on and
you go okay I guess they just felt like
they had to do it but then it happens a
second time another dream sequence and
it's at that point where I began to
realize this movie is not going anywhere
fast but my real issue with this movie
is its ending which as you guys know I'm
not going to spoil it's one of those
endings where as you're watching it
you're thinking this is kind of
effective this is creepy I thought to
myself okay that is
actually very well done that's creepy
there are some really good shots there's
some good editing there's some good use
of slow motion but it's also the type of
ending that while you're driving home
you sit there and go that doesn't make
sense in retrospect as you look at the
entire film nothing makes sense anymore
and you can sit there and maybe dissect
it to the point where you could in your
own head if you want to say that you
really liked this movie and you can't
admit that it really wasn't that good
you can sit there and say well no this
makes sense and this makes sense and
that happened that way that happened
that way but that would be the Mount
Everest of reaching trust me the ending
just makes the entire film deflate I
appreciated the production values I
appreciated the acting there was some
good direction and a few good scary
moments but overall avoid disappointing
me with its ending it doesn't make sense
the rest of the movie now is just play
I'm gonna give the boy a scene it is
better than most January horror films I
will give it that look forward to Sunday
guys because I'm going to be posting my
review of Tomb Raider my biggest guilty
pleasure movie of all time that's going
to be my newest hilarious T review I
can't wait to share that with you guys
I've had so much fun filming that video
you guys are the best thank you so much
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get steppen
eyes
you